44 AGAINST.
HOWEVER, TWO-THIRDS MAJORITY WAS
NEEDED FOR THE OVERRIDE.
WE ARE GETTING NEW IMAGES
TONIGHT AND WHAT VENEZUELA SAYS
IS THIS SECOND AMERICAN BEHIND A
FAILED PLOT TO OVERTHROW THE
VENEZUELAN GOVERNMENT.
STATE DEPARTMENT CORRESPONDENT
RICH EDSON HAS THE IMAGES.
>> MORE CAPTIVE VIDEOS EMERGED
FROM THE VENEZUELAN GOVERNMENT
OF NICOLAS MADURO.
THESE APPARENTLY OF THE SECOND
FORMER U.S. GREEN BERET IN THE
REGIME’S CUSTODY.
UNDER ARREST, THIS MAN CLAIMS
HE’S AARON BERRY, AND ONE
QUESTION, HE SAYS HE’S PART OF
AN INCURSION INTO VENEZUELA THIS
WEEKEND TO PUSH MADURO FROM
POWER.
THE REGIME ALREADY AIRED A VIDEO
OF A MAN IN CUSTODY CLAIMING TO
BE ANOTHER FORMER GREEN BERET,
MOVE DEAD MEN.
AS THE MADURO REGIME CONTINUES
EXPLAINING THE AMERICANS AND
PROPAGANDA.
NICOLAS MADURO CLAIMS THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT PUSH THE OPERATION.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
DENIES IT.
>> THESE STAFFER THAT WE’VE SEEN
STORIES ON WAS NOT AN AMERICAN
EFFORT.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT MADURO MUST
GO AND WE MUST TRY TO RESTORE
DEMOCRACY FOR THE VENEZUELAN
PEOPLE.
>> ASKING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT U.S.
KNOWLEDGE OF THE OPERATION.
SPOKESPERSON SAYS THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT WAS NOT
INVOLVED IN RECENT EVENTS IN
VENEZUELA INVOLVING
MR. GOUDREAU.
MAJOR DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
UNDERWAY BY THE MADURO CAMPAIGN
MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO SEPARATE
FACTS FROM PROPAGANDA.
THIS SELF-PROCLAIMED ARCHITECT
OF THE PENETRATION INTO
VENEZUELA IS UNDER INVESTIGATION
FOR POTENTIAL ARMS TRAFFICKING
VIOLATIONS.
U.S. OFFICIALS SAY THEY ARE
LOOKING INTO THE FLORIDA
CONTRACTOR AND X GREEN BERET,
JORDAN GOUDREAU, THE MADURO
REGIME SAYS IT WANTS TO
EXTRADITE GOUDREAU.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS IT
WILL USE ALL AVAILABLE TOOLS TO
TRY TO FREE THE AMERICANS FOR
MADURO’S CUSTODY THOUGH THE
UNITED STATES HAS NO OFFICIAL
RELATIONSHIP MADURO’S GOVERNMENT
AS IT IS INSTEAD TRYING TO PUSH